les réunions s'enchaînent pour tenter de
former un nouveau gouvernement après la
démission du premier ministre josé paix
comptait il ya deux semaines c'est mario
draghi qui est chargé de former une
nouvelle coalition à l'ancien président
de la banque centrale européenne il ne
manque que le ralliement du mouvement 5
étoiles le parti laisse le soin à ses
militants de décider grâce à un vote en
ligne ce jeudi après midi
nous laisserons nos membres s'exprimer
et ils nous donneront une indication de
la direction à prendre comme nous
l'avons toujours fait avec les
gouvernements précédents
cette fois ci également nous comptons
sur l'intelligence du groupe pour faire
le bon choix dans l'intérêt du pays et
non dans d'autres intérêts merci on
attendront mario draghi a reçu des
soutiens de poids notamment celui du
leader de la ligue du nord matteo
salvini ou encore l'ancien premier
ministre silvio berlusconi chef du parti
forza italia
nous jouerons notre rôle de manière
loyale et constructive
la gravité du moment exige que chacun
mette de côté les calculs les tactiques
et les intérêts électoraux pour faire
passer le salut du pays avant tout si
cela se produit je suis certain que
l'italie pourra à nouveau se relever et
aller de l'avant
si le mouvement 5 étoiles apporte son
soutien à draghi
ce dernier pourrait annoncer dès demain
la composition de son cabinet et
demander un vote de confiance au
parlement en début de semaine prochaine
le temps presse car la plupart des
mesures de lutte contre l'épidémie de
kovy 19 expire ce lundi pour prolonger
l'interdiction de se déplacer entre les
régions où le couvre-feu
un nouveau décret nécessaire en italie
la pandémie a fait plus de 92 mille
morts